what is the craziest thing you've seen
like since you've started botched I
think it was maybe our second season we
had a lady come on who had very large
breast implants but they became
calcified so they're rock hard
she used to out make a living by doing
breaking things with her breasts so she
we put a watermelon there yeah and she
took her breast and she broke the
watermelon I know if they saw that and
then he hoped would you have like a beer
can in a beer can beer can buy this and
she crushed a beer can right with his
ham was there that was probably one of
the craziest things but she was so
successful at it she bought an island I
mean she this is actually quite wealthy
doing those yes so do you this is crazy
have you guys ever like done anything
that's that like makes you feel queasy
or you guys just have like steel
stomachs well that started off for me
when we started medical school and by
the way you started when you're young
you're a detecting frogs yeah nothing
grossed me out you know I mean I can cut
up the frog or look at the bugs but it's
funny but if you deliver me food that
has a face on it I can't eat it all it
grosses me out and that weird you know
medical school we worked on cadavers on
the beginning you're kind of freaking
out but that looks you know after a
while you kind of get used to it but in
what you can do to help people to like
not just for aesthetic purposes but
actually like saving their lives it's
incredible what an incredible gift you
both have I mean we're lucky to have
this are not a gift you worked hard for
it as well and this goods wouldn't just
gifted to you yeah you have to work hard
to be a doctor a lot of schooling
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going